what are the big challenges to you in uh
colonizing mars from a biology
perspective from a human perspective
from an engineering perspective
there's several big challenges to mars
and even the first one is even just the
word colonized so i think we there's
even a social challenge like a lot of
people
um danielle wood actually studies this
at mit
is
sh we shouldn't even use the word
colonized but then we probably shouldn't
use the word settle either because
there's settlements that have some other
baggage to that word as well and then
maybe we just use the word explore but
at some point you didn't say we're going
there to survive there and so
colonization still is the word most
people use but i try to say go explore
and build or settle but i think the
first challenge is is social i think
getting people to think that this will
not be like the colonization efforts of
the past the hope is that this will be a
very different version of humanity
exploring that's my hope
history has you could say has proved me
wrong every single time like every time
humans have gone somewhere it's usually
been a tale of exploitation strife
and and drama again and then and and
often murder genocide like it's actually
a pretty dark history if you think of
just all the colonization efforts but i
think
most of it was done in a really dark
area of humanity where there was average
life expectancy was more than half less
than it was today it was uh life was uh
british and short as many of as hobbs
famously said so
it was
it was a rough existence right so i
think some of the the the ugliness of
humanity in prior colonization times was
was a consequence at the time and at
least that's my hope i think that now we
would have it be much more i think uh
inclusive much more responsible much
more
much less you know evil frankly like
we'd go there and
you would need commercialization you
need efforts to do mining for example
bring things back but it'd have to be
some degree where there are some areas
that are viewed as as as commons or that
are untouchable like places that are
parks we do this today even if there's a
lake for example the first you know
several hundred feet of a lake are all
for public property and everything you
can own property but just not certain
barriers so i think we have to make sure
we do that so that it's not completely
exploited but the so that's on the
social the human side the technological
we've talked a little bit about where
you'd have to live you want to be
underground with engineering and
modifying even human cells to make sure
you survive
the soil does have a lot of perchlorates
which is a problem for growing them but
there's ways to extract them there's a
fair amount of water there's actually a
beautiful image of all the known water
on mars that nasa posted about a year
ago and there's water everywhere not not
lots of it everywhere but you almost
everywhere you look there's at least a
little bit of water just a few feet
under the surface and by the caps
there's a lot so i think
we could get some water and we could
also do you know self-generating
reactors machines that could make food
start to even make beer
if you go long enough down the path but
the technical challenges are definitely
the
engineering and the manufacturing are
going to be hard because you have to
build the buildings basically out of the
soil that's there so you have to really
go there and try and build whatever you
can so that has to be perfected still
but then once you're in those those
buildings those structures you need to
create all the biology that will feed
the the populous feed them so
which we don't have the technology for
yet we have bits of it but i think
that's going to be the biggest challenge
is
making mars really truly independent but
that'll probably take them as i say in
the book several hundred years before i
think we'd get there
it's interesting because we're also
exploring
ways to motivate
society to take on this challenge
it's the jfk thing
and then the cold war that inspired
the race to space
and i think as a human species we're
actually trying to figure out different
ideas for how to motivate everybody to
work on the same project together
but yet competed at the same time well
that's one idea and that's worked well
competition competition that's not
necessarily the only idea but it's one
that worked well so far so maybe the
only way to truly build the colony
in uh on mars
or a successful sort of human
civilization on mars
is to get like china to get
like uh competitive about it i think
well and they are they've announced they
want to have boots on the red planet by
2033 which is two to four years earlier
than when nasa's supposed to do it so
we'll see if they if they get there
first but i think it's a space race 2.0
but it's not just the us and russia this
time it's china it's india it's the uae
it's europe esa
jax has the japanese space agency and
there's the us now
it went from just a two-person race to
you know a whole field at the you know
the
whole field of
runners if you will on the track trying
to get to mars first and i think
i mean i think this can be like anything
if you start to have settlements and
construction projects in places to visit
on mars i think that the true mark of of
some place being actually settled is
when
you you start to be able to pick you're
like well i want to go to this
destination not this one because they
have better martian cocktails here but
then this one's not as good so then the
this idea of innovating competing will
continue to drive i think
humans as it always has